still can't believe that ending john  what a thrill a company in parole says  surveillance video showing thieves  stealing an  excavator from a job site this all  happened sunday right near highway 160  and postal drive  now they're asking for your help to get  it back the family that owns 3d  construction hopes you can recognize  this white colored pickup truck degan  reilly says they filed a police report  with the nye county sheriff's office  after the two men took off with their  equipment the duo is also accused of  stealing ramps from a nearby motorcycle  shop  to load the excavator into the truck  from watching the videos it looks like  these people know what they were doing  because we've we've hired new people and  had them  try to run our excavators and they get  on there it looks like  a six-year-old trying to run it now we  are told this particular excavator brand  new  is worth over twenty thousand dollars  the company had to buy a new one to  replace it